il ya deux pays en revanche qu'ils ont
une très longue culture du renseignement
de l'espionnage c'est la grande bretagne
et la russie
vous expliquez pourquoi d'ailleurs d'une
certaine manière la russie ça remonte
trait aux arts pierre le grand qui est
le fondateur de l'empiré russe ou au
début du xviiie siècle et qui est le
premier art a quitté son pays et à venir
en europe occidentale
il veut moderniser la russie donc
s'inspirer de ce qui se passe au même
moment en prusse en france en angleterre
aux pays bas ou en italie et donc il ya
des ambassadeurs qui viennent et lui il
se met dans le dans la suite des
ambassadeurs et incognito il se fait
engager alors qui pour devenir
artilleurs en prusse ou sur les
chantiers navals aux pays bas et en
angleterre
ce serait ça au fond l'origine de la
culture de l'espionnage et du
renseignement
chez les russes à écouter toute façon
c'est en fait voilà ça c'est c'est
historique
il ya un hasard un souverain il y avait
qu comme vous l'avez très bien dit bon
requis qui s'est hissée me incognito
dans ce qu'on appelait la rendra
ambassade en 797
ou la russie avait besoin de trouver des
alliés en europe et 7 cette mission
était conduite par d
des proches du zar mais lui il était là
incognito comme vous l'a justement dit
libre où il se fait artilleurs en prusse
charpentier dans les provinces unies
il était allé acheter des plants de
navires en angleterre et ça c'est quand
même incroyable
imaginez-vous en france un seul droit
qui comme ça et a passé pratiquement un
an incognito pour aller 8 même se rendre
compte où en était l'état de les hauts
niveaux de la technologie ou au niveau
des techniques c'est l'odeur lui-même
qui l'a fait alors effectivement on peut
penser que ça remonte à cette époque là
il faut pas oublier qu'après bon
lorsqu'on parle de renseignements il ya
le conseil mme en extérieur mais les
renseignant aussi internes et
malheureusement le renseignement interne
ça peut être également des des polices
politiques et dieu sait si les russes
enfin la russie tsariste avait des
couilles c'est vraiment fort
[Musique]